what's up everybody I'm Nick scarpino
here with mr. Alfredo Diaz how you doing
bud up its rainbow sick your excited
look at you guys anyways good oh well
with me how's it looking for you it's
it's I mean we played we I got my hands
on with the pc multiplayer I think it
was like the closed alpha and it played
great yeah now that we have some week
they're bringing back okay they call it
tarot hunt mm-hmm I'm gonna call it
terrorist hunt yeah that's what come on
but yeah so they brought back Terrace
huh and that's just a fan favorite yeah
absolutely so this is the game mode
where it's sensually you and your
fellows SWAT members that are controlled
by your friends and you go in and you
have a certain amount of terrorists that
you just have to eliminating kill mm-hmm
it's pretty plain simple but it can't
get very difficult if you turn up the
difficulty yeah i mean like balls hard
so for people who aren't really familiar
with rainbow sex how does that differ
from so many other popular shoes so
you're looking at call of duty when
you're looking at halo those are really
like fast-paced like go run get killed
if you die is not big that much of a
penalty you come back really quick right
away games like Rainbow six are more
they're slow pace their tactical the
methodical right mmm your life is much
more valuable facet or to it slightly
more something good part oh yeah that's
cuz I question the delicate watching the
guys watch yeah so we should we should
know that the of course this is from the
e3 conference that's what we're seeing
this footage here what are we seen here
so this is just one of like the many
tools that you have as a swap member and
as a part of the rainbow six squad and
this is a little camera the control a
little drones go around so essentially
you're just trying to survey like what
their setup is gonna mean you and the
thing about like sees is so great is
that you can attack rooms from any
different angle right like oh there's
that that wall there sure just blow
right through it yeah just go right in
you know which is awesome and then I
mean on the from the multiplayer
perspective you can seal up certain
walls and stuff like that too so you can
really like barricade yourself in I
think the whole dog destructive
environment thing just kind of adds is
really cool next-gen
and uh gameplay to the whole readjust
only has the dimension to it right hey I
mean probably for longer than prior game
06 a games you had doors that you could
explore you can burst in right yeah you
could breach them I can always be
shadows you had of course we saw the
beginning of this commentary we saw them
hanging upside down doing that all in
fun stuff marking your targets yeah kind
of like that which all I assume we're
all still be in this exam but this just
looks like it's taking it up a whole
other level it's it's fun you know it's
just it's a game Modell that a lot of
people love right this is something that
like Colin would play more than then
than anyone else you know right someone
doesn't want to really play the
multiplayer too much but they do love
that kind of like the aspect of like
playing it's AI so this will be more of
like that kind of persons game game mode
but it's still fun and like I said it's
challenging if you turn difficulty up
like you hit that corner you're not even
paying attention like they will light
you up let's see how light that's what I
liked about this you know did the
rainbow six series in general is there
is that tactical feeling to it right you
do have to sort of think a little bit
about it definite and in that there is
an added dimension of fun it's not just
to it shooter it's not just no reaction
it really is sort of like let's think
let's play and let's have fun doing that
exactly so my question for you is what
do I have to do what how many pushups
have to be able to do to be on your team
oh there's not enough cuz I know there's
not enough we kind of just have you sit
off to like you know to the back with a
car for a second and if everyone dies
would be like Nick I guess it's in your
hand okay I think I could take at least
one person out on this haha I'm not
quite sure what's going on with that guy
with the shield what just happened there
he's you know that's your boy he's the
one that that's leading the charge right
now I love that these poochie's
protecting protecting everyone oh god
how badly do you gun control in your
hand right there ah you know it's it
plays well it feels good and I know it's
just it's so fun cuz I'm like you know I
could breach the walls like that some
parts of the ground you can breach like
down to the bottom two as well so low
you can it's it's sick Nick not sound
excited man I'm excited me can enter in
from all kinds of ways and direct okay
now we're getting now we're getting
sexual now it's we were clearly I didn't
you gotta clean this is video games
there's nothing sexual or over violence
to edit you know none of this
alfreda you are the man and the rainbow
six is the game thank you so much for
joining I thank you everyone out there
stay tuned for more